good afternoon I love when people
respond back any more of that thank you
wake up wake up I am thrilled to be one
of the keynote speakers for this year's
strange loop but before I get started
talking about the idea of the
intersection between humanities and
technology I wanted to start off with
something that I'm almost embarrassed to
admit and it's the fact that ever since
i moved to apples platform after college
I realized that I don't seem to know a
single technical specification of any of
my devices i'm lucky if i could tell you
the capacity of my iphone or my iPad but
i certainly don't know the clock speed
of this retina macbook pro that i'm
using or how much memory is in my ipad
mini 4 and that's weird for me i'm a
technical person a programmer by trade
my family has zero problem asking me
every technical question they can or
just asking me to build them a nap in
high school I used to build gaming PC's
every month I read maximum pc covered a
cover I could have told you the
transistor count on my graphics card I
could have told you the clock speed of
Intel's entire lineup so what happened
why has Apple gotten me comfortable
existing in this space where I just
assume that every year they'll come out
with a new version of the product that i
love and it'll be half the size and
twice as fast why am i frankly a bit
comfortable with being hardware dumb so
i started thinking thinking about the
medium that Apple uses to communicate
with its customers or its potential
customers and that's commercials so
really it's apple's fault that I don't
know this stuff Apple commercials are
much more about the experience of using
one of their products it goes back to
the idea of speed
and feeds and how there was no longer a
need for Apple to compete on technical
merit moving forward it was simply about
the quality of the user's experience an
apple does just a far better job at this
than the competition I mean sure not
every commercial is amazing certainly
not the series of apple genius ads but
more often than not the quality of their
commercials is found and how well they
show you one of their products fitting
into your everyday life i'm not using
keynote all right we're going without
notes it's fine all right you were
supposed to see this when I got to
commercials and then you were supposed
to see this when I made fun of bad apple
commercials the series of apple genius
ads most unfortunate as I was saying
more often than not the quality of their
commercials is found in how well they
show you one of their products fitting
into your everyday life and I can't
think of a better representation of this
than apples misunderstood ad from a few
years ago now this may be a commercial
you've seen before but just in case you
haven't in it a teenage boy is on
holiday vacation with this family and he
seems like the typical aloof teenager
who would rather be anywhere but there
he spends the entire time buried in this
phone and to be honest you almost want
to smack the kid tell him hey pay
attention these are going to be the
moments that you're going to be sorry
you missed out on when you're older that
you're going to wish you cherished but
instead he spends the entire time buried
in this phone and it's funny because at
the end of the commercial you find out
that he's been on his phone this entire
time
putting together this beautiful video
montage of the family's greatest moments
it's this awesome moment when he reveals
it a haunting rendition of Judy
Garland's have yourself a merry little
Christmas is playing in the background
the family starts crying when they see
the video he starts crying and if they
were sound on we'd probably be crying
too and this commercial works right I
certainly couldn't wait to run and grab
my own iPhone and take pictures and
video of my family doing anything and
everything just to hold on to those
moments but when you think about it not
a single technical specification is
mentioned in the entire commercial you
don't know what megapixel camera he used
to shoot the video you don't know how
many videos could be stored on his phone
and you don't even know what app he used
to edit the video and none of that seems
to matter now I don't want to pick on
anyone but i would like to compare this
to an android commercial
remember these absurd android
commercials the ones that used to yell
out droid in this weird robotic voice at
the end just take it all in you look at
one of these commercials and it's so
confusing it's so impersonal what in the
hell has any of this got to do with the
experience of using a phone it might be
one of the most technology for
technology's sake productions that I
could possibly imagine Michael Bay would
be proud and so I wondered I wondered
and looking at the misunderstood ad and
then looking at this ridiculous android
commercial what is it about Apple
commercials that's so much more exciting
and engaging to me it just keeps getting
better why when I see the silhouette of
a person am I really into it because I
realized that an ipod commercial is
about to come on so I thought about it
and I think I think it goes back to this
it goes back to this idea of the
intersection between liberal arts and
technology this is a photo from steve
jobs as last keynote the march two
thousand eleven ipad 2 event the words
that accompany this photo are seen as
jobs as legacy to apple and
representative of the fact that Apple
first creates the user experience and
then they create the technology to fit
that user experience they don't try to
shoehorn technology in and so as a
result Apple products are much more
experiential it's about what you can do
with them now the words that accompany
this photo are worth repeating because
Jobs was right he was right when he said
it's in Apple's DNA that technology
alone is not enough
its technology married with the liberal
arts married with the humanities that
yields us the results that make our
heart sing whoo it's this beautiful
quote who doesn't want to make products
and experiences that make other people's
heart sing I know I certainly strive to
do that and I'm sure you do as well and
we've seen over the years that Apple
embodies the spirit of this quote but
what does it mean to apply these
thoughts practically particularly for
companies or projects outside of Apple
and so this is what I want to spend some
time digging into I want to talk about
real-world practical applications of
this intersection between humanities and
Technology and I think it's best to
start with where jobs got the idea of
the center section from and that was his
hero dr. Edwin land the founder of
Polaroid an inventor of instant
photography dr. land wholeheartedly
believed in this intersection between
Arts and Sciences he saw photography as
existing at this very intersection dr.
land would hire the smartest art history
majors he could and he would send them
off for a few science classes
effectively creating people who stood at
this very intersection throughout his
company but it's not like the idea of
the intersection started with dr. land
no in the 15th century Leonardo da Vinci
was both an artist and a scientist
because in his day there was no
distinction I could do an entire talk on
the works of da Vinci and how they
relate to the intersection of humanities
and technology one minute da Vinci was
painting the Mona Lisa or the Last
Supper and the next he was
conceptualising helicopters calculators
and solar power
one of da Vinci's most recognizable
works the virtru vian man combines art
anatomy and geometry to metaphorically
solve the problem of squaring the circle
likewise in the 19th century Ada
Lovelace coined the term poetical
science to describe the intersection of
her studies Lovelace the daughter of
poet Lord Byron and skilled
mathematician lady Byron used beautiful
metaphors to explain complex
mathematical concepts it was Lovelace's
perspective at this intersection that
caused her to go beyond the
number-crunching capabilities of
machines and to instead focus on how
humans and society could leverage
technology as a collaborative tool so
now dr. LAN didn't create the idea of
this intersection but what made him
great is that he understood that people
did not need to know how a product
worked in order to enjoy and appreciate
the experience of using it and dr. land
used this knowledge to create the sx-70
camera which he's seen here holding it's
probably his finest achievement the
sx-70 didn't usher in instant
photography dr. land had done that 30
years prior but what it did is it made
it easy for the average person to create
a memory instantly you didn't have to
worry about film Dunkey film paper or
film chemicals getting on your hands and
possibly burning them you didn't have to
concern yourself with how much battery
to take along with you to take all the
photos you wanted because the battery
was built into the film and the
interface was super simple just 22
controls a scroll wheel to take the
focus the shot and a shutter button to
take the photo that's it
naturally hiding all of this complexity
from the user meant that there was a ton
of complexity within the camera does
this sound familiar to anyone it feels
like all we do sometimes as developers
and designers is we strive to create
these simple and intuitive interfaces
we'll spend weeks if not longer on the
workflow behind a single button and we
pray that when we introduced that button
that people just get it and it makes
sense and dr. land was doing this in the
1970s he understood that if you removed
the complexity from the process of
taking photos that people would instead
focus on the art of photography and dr.
LAN didn't just want to sell cameras no
he wanted to fundamentally change the
ways in which people interacted with
each other and he succeeded dr. land
delighted in seeing people excited to
jump into group photos take photos of
one another and share them I could only
imagine what he would have thought of
selfie sticks today but this camera came
out in the 1970s and so I'd like to jump
again to a more modern representation of
this intersection this video game named
never alone and it's one of the finest
examples we have of what happens when
technology leverages the insights of the
humanities never alone was created in
partnership between the Cook Inlet
Tribal Council a foundation that
supports the Alaskan native people and
II line media a publisher of educational
entertainment now the Alaskan native
people were looking for a modern way to
share their language and their culture
with the world and they wanted to do it
in a way that leverage technology and
leveraged media so they partnered with
eline media and what they produced is
this great game in it you play from the
perspective
noona a young Inupiaq girl and her
arctic fox as they set out to find the
source of the eternal blizzard in order
to bring back harmony to the world this
game was created over a two-year period
with nearly 40 NOP ax storytellers
elders and community members all working
directly with game developers and this
was a collaboration in the truest sense
it's not like the NEP at came in for an
afternoon and then the game developers
went off and made this great game now
the NEP act had real say over every
stage of the process from concept to
development and marketing it's amazing
that this game exists at all let alone
the fact that it exists to be both fun
and educational because games like this
are too hard to make you have to do what
I see as get three things right all
while walking this fine line between the
two you have to have a great story to
tell terrific artistry and then you need
to have the technical prowess to be able
to execute on your vision this should
have failed there are plenty of
educational games that exist and they
suck really bad at peeing fun games but
instead of failing the game developers
worked hard to ensure that everything
put into the game was placed there
because it was culturally relevant the
NEP ack believe that man and nature are
equals and so a lot of the obstacles
that noona in the fox face aren't
intentionally trying to bring them harm
likewise every reward was put there with
real intentionality and purpose this
could have been a documentary and in
fact you can unlock video clips within
the game that explained more about the
concept and background but if it had
been a documentary it wouldn't have
reached the audience that it was
intended because at a time when the
Inupiaq feel that
technology and video games are pulling
the youth away from their language and
pulling the youth away from their
culture they're using that same medium
to reconnect back to them it's a
terrific game and I have another that I
want to talk about that exists at this
very intersection and it's called
depression quest depression quest was
released in 2013 by zoe quinn and in it
you play from the perspective of someone
suffering from depression as they
navigate a series of everyday life
events while managing their illness and
their relationships depression quest
plays like a choose your own adventure
game one interesting feature is that as
you progress and your depression worsens
options that would normally be available
to you and helpful in managing your
illness are crossed out representing the
toll that depression can take on your
energy levels the depression quest is
not a fun game to play it's not your
typical health bar or energy bar are
instead replaced by a description of
what medication you're on what your mood
is that day and whether or not you're
seeing a therapist but it provides a
really interesting example of using
technology to illustrate what suffering
from an illness is like and Quinn
created this game with a specific
audience in mind she herself suffers
from depression and she wanted to create
a safe space for those also dealing with
the illness to be able to explore the
implications of it and it's had another
positive side effect as well because
therapists are using the game to build
empathy and understanding with loved
ones of those suffering from depression
technically speaking depression quest is
not fancy it's written in html5 Quinn
uses a static
grey background and atmospheric effects
like music that gets progressively more
glitchy and haunting to help you get
into the headspace of the illness but
the game's still effective and by making
it free and available on the web she's
ensured that it's able to reach and help
as wide an audience as possible and
depression quest is actually part of a
growing genre of games that illustrate
what it's like to interact with the
world from a challenging point of view
with a clever use of game mechanics
these games are simulating what it's
like to be in someone else's shoes and
make choices from their perspective and
it's that piece it's that piece about
making choices from someone else's
perspective that yields a greater sense
of empathy and understanding it's
greater than what we see in linear
mediums like books or movies take the
game that dragon cancer for example it
was made by Ryan and Amy Greene to
explore the struggle they faced his
parents coping with their son Joel's
cancer diagnosis at the age of 1 the
name of the game comes from a story that
Ryan and Amy would tell their other
young children about Jill's illness
likening him to a brave knight fighting
a dragon named cancer when the game
begins joel is five and he's already
been living with cancer for four years
now in that time he's battled eight
tumors and they've taken a toll on his
development the game unfolds like a
series of moments from the family's last
year with Joel you find out for example
that his development has been slowed
during a family outing to feed ducks one
of joel's siblings asks why he doesn't
speak
and as heartbreaking as this moment is
it's the game's use of the family's real
voices that makes you feel like you're
there experiencing it with them another
impactful moment occurs when Ryan and
Amy are given Joel's terminally ill
diagnosis and here an interesting
mechanic is used a child's toy is
displayed with pictures of everyone in
the room and clicking on one of those
pictures of the family members or the
medical staff gives you insight into the
raw emotions that each is experiencing
the kind of thoughts that often go and
said in a difficult situation such as
this unlike most games there are no
super powers granted in that dragon
cancer and another memory we hear Ryan's
agony through poetry as he spends the
night with his son at the hospital
following a stomach infection Joel cries
because he's dehydrated but giving him
juice just makes him throw up despite
Ryan's best attempts he's unable to make
his son feel better and listening to
Joel well through the night and then
hearing Ryan's feelings of helplessness
is sickening Ryan is a bystander to his
son's pain and it's through this lens
that the game conveys its powerful
message moving forward I hope we'll
continue to see games like this that
pushed the boundaries and explored
difficult and complex life issues
because these games have the potential
to help us engage with and understand
someone's perspective in a way we've
never before experienced
one medium that we use right now to
understand someone's perspective in real
time is twitter twitter is a powerful
platform early adopters of it were part
of the technology a lead while generally
speaking everyone who's come since is
far more interested in the capabilities
of the platform than they are and the
technology behind it these days people
join Twitter to build their public brand
or participate in the public discourse
earlier this year I started a non-profit
named sound off and we use crowd fund
raising campaigns to generate donations
for us twitter has been an indispensable
tool and helping us reach a large
audience of people people who've never
heard of me or sound off before at its
best Twitter can be the place where you
learn about the perspective of someone
from an entirely different walk of life
and so as a result twitter has ushered
in hashtag activism it's made human
rights violations that are far away feel
very real and close to home issues like
Arab Spring Ferguson bring back our
girls everyday sexism and black lives
matter have trended worldwide received
mainstream media attention and official
responses from companies and governments
there's something extremely powerful in
seeing hundreds of thousands of people
tweet about inicia it galvanizes creates
real support and awareness that same
power though also has a negative side
and so Twitter is also the platform
where stalkers and harasses run rampant
and they post vile tweets to anyone that
they deem unworthy of having a voice
take what happened recently to Leslie
Jones as an example
just days after the release of
Ghostbusters Leslie was inundated with
vile racist and misogynist tweets to
fight back Leslie began publicizing the
most racist tweets the ones that made
demeaning comments about her appearance
and likened her to a gorilla as if that
wasn't enough the trolls then took to
mocking up fake tweets authored by
Leslie Jones with homophobic slurs and
they spread these tweets on the internet
as if they were real so at one point
Leslie was being inundated with missing
with messages from malicious trolls as
well as misinformed users who thought
she herself was spreading hate this
lasted all day and in that time Leslie
pleaded with Twitter to help she asked
why they weren't doing more to prevent
the abuse she was receiving she wondered
how the hate could be left to just
fester and spread and she thought there
should be some guidelines against what
she was experiencing but after 10 hours
Leslie gave up writing a series of
messages about the personal hell she was
in and how deeply it disturbed her
before signing off for the night and
Twitter they stood idly by as the
situation unfolded and escalated when
asked about the targeted abuse live as
it was happening Twitter had this to say
to BuzzFeed news they said while we
don't comment on individual accounts
here's an explainer on our content
boundaries and hopefully they included a
link to their policies it actually
wasn't until the CEO of Twitter Jack
Dorsey stepped in to help that Leslie
began to experience some reprieve and 24
hours later Twitter
again suspending accounts but allow me
to state the obvious it shouldn't take
the CEO of Twitter stepping in for some
action to be taken to mitigate the issue
of targeted harassment and if Twitter
can't protect Leslie Jones who was just
in a summer blockbuster movie then what
about the rest of us well we do know
what happens to the rest of us because
this isn't the first instance of
targeted abuse we've seen on Twitter
we've seen gamer gate in June New York
Times editor John Weisman quit the
service after receiving a slew of
anti-semitic messages in April ESPN put
out a PSA with men reading real tweets
to two of ESPN's women's sports writers
and this was all done in an effort to
try to curb the disgusting messages that
they are inundated with daily and we've
also seen unfortunately that when these
instances of abuse are reported users
are left scratching their head wondering
how the hate they've received on the
platform couldn't possibly be against
Twitter's rules and Twitter they're
fully aware of the problem so much so
that the previous CEO said in an
internal email we suck at dealing with
abuse and trolls on the platform and
we've sucked at it for years and he's
right Twitter does suck at this issue
twitter has to decide what kind of
platform it wants to be and it needs to
do it now because it's an action is
speaking volumes there's a common trend
on Twitter of attacks happening too
visible women and minorities already
vulnerable groups in society and twitter
has a responsibility to these people to
not lose track of their humanity simply
because this is a
no problem when these instances of abuse
happened Twitter always says they're
working to get better by improving their
tools and their enforcement systems but
I'm not sure what that means we already
know of strategies that help make online
communities better we already know that
clear guidelines a commitment to
enforcing those guidelines and timely
enforcement works extremely well so in
the case of Leslie Jones you can't take
24 hours to respond to the targeted
abuse that she was receiving and for non
celebrities on Twitter you cannot send a
message that the vitriol and hate
they've received on your platform is
somehow not against your rules Twitter
that's not against your guidelines maybe
it's time to reassess them then about
four months before the targeted abuse
that Leslie Jones received on Twitter
Microsoft put out a chat bot named Ted
and Tay wasn't just any chat bot Tay had
artificial intelligence and the ability
to learn from other users on Twitter
really Microsoft was conducting research
into conversational understanding and
its goal was for tay to get
progressively smarter by interacting
with other users on Twitter actually how
many of you here have active Twitter
accounts whew almost everyone so you're
probably not surprised to find out then
that within hours the users that
interacted with tay turned it into a
racist misogynist truther taste started
off extremely innocent look how excited
it was to talk to humans and within
hours
tay was today was a bit less enthused
Tay tweeted extremely offensive beliefs
further attacking those already
vulnerable groups on the platform
calling for a race war and a genocide
there are so many things that I find
remarkable about this story even Clippy
is confused I wonder how Microsoft
thought it was a good idea to release a
bot that could learn from other users on
Twitter to begin with but mostly I
wonder how a was left to tweet
disgusting things for hours how was teh
not monitored Microsoft you have a
responsibility to people to monitor the
technology that you release support
means more than simply assessing uptime
and availability support means making
sure that the products you put out into
the world are not inflicting pain on
other people where were you when taste
started attacking vulnerable people on
the platform and I think most
confusingly there were simple safeguards
that Microsoft could have put in place
but chose not to why for example was teh
allowed to tweeted anyone including
people that hadn't tweeted it it and why
weren't certain words just marked as off
limits it's not surprising to me that
malicious users trolled Microsoft's
attempt at corporate PR because make no
mistake that's what Tay is tay is a bot
designed to understand how Millennials
think so that Microsoft could better
target them in marketing campaigns look
at taste profile on Twitter who talks
like that
I bet Microsoft thinks Millennials with
disposable income do eventually
Microsoft shut tay down tweeting one
last time from the account before making
tweets private you can't break character
right after Tay was shut down
Microsoft's VP of research released an
official apology and for the most part
this is your typical corporate apology
it mentioned how a was tested with a
diverse group of users and how taze
tweets do not reflect the beliefs of its
creators or their values what I found
most interesting though is that the VP
pointed to a similar experiment
successfully conducted in China as being
the inspiration for tet well-being the
naturally curious person that I am I
just had to know what made this bot in
China so much more successful than Ted
are there just kinder people in China so
I went looking and what I found was an
article written by the lead of the team
that manages the bots in China name's
Joe ice and as I read the article what
struck me is how dramatically different
the tone of it was in comparison to what
had been written about Ted the word
empathy was used several times to
describe how ice in fact July stores the
users mood not their information so that
it can bring a level of empathy to every
conversation emotional intelligence is
so valued on this team that software
engineers and psychologists both are on
it this is what made shall is more
successful than Taye and it's really
what I want to hear from Microsoft's
development team as they look ahead to
the future of Ted I don't want to hear
about how you can't predict every use of
how someone will interact with the
technology that you release what I want
to hear is how you're going to
build a level of empathy and
understanding and today moving forward I
want to know that Microsoft has looked
beyond their own profits when thinking
about who could benefit from this
technology I want to know that Microsoft
has really done their research on who
could possibly be harmed by this
technology and that they've looked
looked for non-obvious perspectives
entirely different from their own I bet
the team that worked on Tay is just as
technically proficient as the people
behind shall ice the difference here
between building something awesome and
building something harmful is that one
team had an explicit goal of empathy and
it was informed by their humanity it
doesn't matter how cool the technology
you create us or how great your
algorithms are if you don't take a
moment to consider the people that might
interact with the products that you
release and frankly this is something
that I work on myself I keep it posted
at my desk simply to remind myself that
the oftentimes homogenous environment
that I live and work in in Silicon
Valley does not represent the greater
world out there or the types of people
that could use one of my products I need
to keep myself reminded of my blind
spots and sometimes I wonder who on
these teams is making sure that product
design and engineering are thinking and
creating with their blind spots in mind
more and more I'm starting to feel like
you actually shouldn't be allowed to
build a product until you've put in your
10,000 hours not on learning about
technology but on learning about other
cultures languages and experiences how
often do you get out of your own social
media bubble how diverse is your network
and this is a learning initiative that
won't ever end eventually my blind spots
will evolve over time and I'll have a
new post it to help me keep everyone in
mind I'd like to talk about another
place where I've seen the intersection
of humanities and Technology pop up
recently and it was somewhere unexpected
gadget reviews after the introduction of
the Apple watch BuzzFeed sent two of
their journalists to record a video of
themselves trying on and using the watch
for the first time now the video review
that they've recorded has been seen over
2 million times it's been retweeted by
the official iTunes account by all
metrics it's an incredibly successful
gadget review video what's interesting
though is that not a single technical
specification is mentioned in the entire
video and instead what you get is tons
of personality you get lots of emotion
the women talk about how the watch feels
natural where how it might fit into
their everyday lives they talk about how
they feel like a Power Ranger while
wearing it honestly this gadget review
video was focused similarly to Apple's
own keynote which didn't talk about
technical features like the digital
crown but instead focused on what it was
like to wear the watch while running a
marathon and I feel like this gadget
review video is representative of an
evolution taking place for gadget
reviews to be how video game reviews
have always been which is focused on the
meaning behind a product and what it
means to you to use it there's always
going to be a place for purely technical
reviews they're not going anywhere but I
feel like especially as people get
busier and busier there's also a space
for
reviews that simply explain whether or
not a product is worth your time to
investigate further or the emotion
behind it speaking of using technology
to evoke emotion I can't think of a
better place than Pixar Pixar is the
company that produces the most
technologically advanced animations on
earth that make you want to cry I'm
convinced that's their business plan I
couldn't wait to see toy story 3 and by
the end I had burst into tears I hear
they're coming out with a toy story 4
and I don't think I'm ready for it yet
how many of you have seen the first 10
minutes of up yeah yeah you know what
I'm talking about in it there's a four
minute montage with the older main
character as you experience his marriage
to his wife you see the joy they
experience when they get married the
sadness and despair they feel at their
inability to have children and the utter
depression that he falls into when his
wife passes away every time I see up
it's a terrible experience at least that
beginning part pics are supposed to
produce cartoons right but their
storytelling is so creative and it's so
relatable that it transcends the medium
of animation and it's no coincidence
that Pixar is one of the most creative
places on earth in november two thousand
steve jobs purchase 16 acres of
abandoned canning factory land just
north of oakland california the original
plans for Pixar's campus called for
three separate buildings there was to be
one for the computer scientists one for
the animators and one for the executives
naturally though jobs scrap those plans
entirely and instead of three separate
buildings he built a single building
with a vast atrium at its center and
this is because jobs rightly understood
that creativity happens when people of
different disciplines are exposed to one
another and so he put the most important
function of the building which was
facilitating this interaction at its
core it wasn't enough though for jobs
simply to create the space of course not
he wanted to make sure that people
actually went there and so first he
moved the meeting rooms there he moved
to the cafeteria there the mailboxes the
cafe the gift shop it got so bad that
jobs mandated that the only set of
bathrooms could be built inside the
atrium thankfully for Pixar employees he
was later forced to concede on this last
point now of the atrium Brad Bird the
director of ratatouille and the
incredibles had this to say regarding
the atrium he said the atrium initially
might seem like a waste of space but
Steve realized that when people run into
each other and when they make eye
contact things happen and John Lasseter
the chief creative officer at Pixar had
this to say regarding the intersection
he said technology inspires art and art
challenges the technology and I can't
think of anybody that challenged the
technology more so than jobs one of the
reasons jobs is so loved is that he went
off and he studied non-traditional
engineering disciplines he took ballroom
dancing he took calligraphy
and that he used his unique perspective
to infuse the liberal arts into his
products job saw himself as a humanities
person first that loved electronics and
similarly I see myself as a humanities
person first that loves technology my
introduction of programming was a friend
giving me C++ in 21 days when I was in
sixth grade and being the absolute type
a kid that I was I just knew that I was
going to learn C++ in exactly 21 days I
had no idea what C++ was but honestly I
was doing pretty well at it I really was
until I got two day eight pointers and
it was at this moment that I hit a brick
wall with my learning I didn't
understand pointers so I couldn't move
on to the next day and this initial
experience with programming shaped how I
viewed it for a really long time I was
always afraid that there would be a new
brick wall concept that would get in my
way and impede my learning my favorite
class in high school was humanities it
was a combination of English and history
and so because my favorite class wasn't
math or science which I was told were
the natural corollaries to programming I
didn't initially see how I could fit
into this space and so one of the things
I've been most excited to see is an
evolution take place in the ways in
which we introduce people to programming
I cheered this past June when Apple
announced their new ipad app Swift
playgrounds this iPad app has the
potential to be the most fun and
engaging way to learn how to program
just look at its 3d graphics and because
students can code directly on the device
they have easy access to multi-touch the
accelerometer and the gyroscope I know
one of the difficulties for me when I
initially learned how to program was
figuring out how those concepts could be
applied practically what can I make with
what I just learned making a calculator
in terminal wasn't exciting to me I
already owned the calculator but I feel
like the built-in graphical and audio
capabilities inside of this app are
going to make this an inherently
exciting prospect to a whole new
generation of aspiring coders that said
Apple products are premium and so I'm
also happy to see initiatives available
at various socio-economic levels one
such free initiative is one hour of code
by code org and in it you drag
programmable blocks in order to maneuver
the angry bird to its destination and so
esoteric texts like the one I picked up
as a kid are being replaced by these fun
and these imaginative tutorials they're
full of encouragement it make you feel
like anyone has a right to learn how to
program that everyone should give it a
shot if they want to and that everyone
can learn if they want and these
tutorials have had such reach that even
President Obama has gotten involved and
so I'm hopeful I'm hopeful that through
resources like Khan Academy and code.org
we're going to continue to grow the pool
of who has access to learning about
programming and learning about
technology because this is what our
industry needs we need a demystification
that doesn't make people feel like they
need to be preternaturally gifted or a
genius in order to learn how to program
programming is a skill
you work at it like anything else it's
important to me that kids who don't feel
particularly adept at math or at science
still feel like they can make a
meaningful contribution to technology
and one of the more exciting things for
me in doing the research for this
keynote has been seeing just how
important the people who stand at this
intersection of humanities and
technology are for the continued
innovation and evolution of our industry
thank you